رغم السعر الماهض لنظاره ابل جديده يتوقع
المحللون ان تنجح في بيع ما يصل الى 150
الف من نظراتها بعد عام طرحها في الاسواق
لكن ما هي انواع النظارات الذكيه نظارات
الواقع الافتراضي في ار تعمل على عزل
مستخدم تماما عن العالم الخارجي ونقله
لبيئه رقميه جديده ولعل اولى هذه التجارب
خرجت من شركه الالعاب نايندو وسيجا في
التسعينات لكنها كانت مكلفه وغير فعاله
اما نظرات الواقع المعزز اي ار فتعمل على
دمج العناصر الرقميه في العالم المادي
بحيث يشعر المستخدم بان تلك العناصر جزء
من الواقع ابرز الامثله عليها لعبه
بوكيمون جو التي حققت ضجه عالميه في 2016
اخيرا نظرت الواقع المختلط ام ار وهي
التقنيه التي تعتمدها نظاره
وهي مزيج يزيل الفوارق بين الواقع
الافتراضي والعالم الحقيقي بمعنى ان يكون
نصفك في العالم المادي والنصف الاخر
يتفاعل مع البيئات الرقميه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات